اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدون مشاهدينا
المستمرون معكم في تغطيتنا للتطورات
المتلاحقه في السودان حيث فشلت هدنه
الاربع والعشرين ساعه المعلنه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في الصمود وتم رصد
اشتباكات متفرقه في الخرطوم ومدن اخرى
بعضها بالاسلحه الثقيله تبادل الجيش
والدعم السريع الاتهامات بشان خرق الهدنه
ما ينذر التوتر بتفاقم الاوضاع الانسانيه
في البلاد التي تعاني منذ سنوات
جرازات سياسيه واقتصاديه
[موسيقى]
في اول رد فعل له اتهم الجيش قوه الدعم
السريع بعدم الالتزام بالهدنه المؤقته
وقال المتحدث الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني
العميد نبيل عبد الله ان الدعم السريع
انتهك وقفه اطلاق النار الذي تم الاتفاق
عليه بموجب بواسطه دوليه قال عبد الله
ايضا ان قوات الدعم السريعه لم تتوقف
مناوشاتها في محيط القياده وفي مدينتي
مروي والخرطوم بحري وكده ان الجيش سيواصل
عملياته للتامين العاصمه والمناطق الاخرى
المقابل اتهمت قوات الدعم السريع هي
الاخرى الجيش بمسؤوليته عن خرق الهدنه
واضافت ان الجيش مستمر في شن هجمات باسلحه
ثقيله على مواقع تمركز عناصرها لافته الى
استمرار الجيش في تحريك قوات عسكريه من
مختلف المدن الى الخرطوم الدعم السريع زعم
ان طائرات حربيه للجيش قصف التجمعات سكنيه
ما تسبب في اصابه ومقتل مدنيين وتدمير
مستشفيات
هذا واظهرت الصور واثار قسط طالع مجمع
الرواد السكني في العاصمه الخرطوم صباح
اليوم في ظل الاقتتال العنيف بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
في هذه الاثناء هز انفجار ضخم مطر الخرطوم
فيما تتواصل المعارك في احدث اشاره على
خرق الهدنه بين طرفي الصراع قال شهود عيان
قديفه اصابت احد خزانات وقود الطائرات في
المطار ما ادى لتصاعد الادخنه الكثيف في
سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
من مدينه مروي ينضمرون مراسل العربيه نزار
بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك اخر المستجدات
المواجهات المسلحه في مرام
[موسيقى]
هل هناك اي تعزيزات من اي طرف كان حول هذه
المدينه الان نزال حتى الان ما يظهر هو
التعزيزات التي تصل للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه
من جهات الجنوبيه لمحليه مروي لكننا لم
نلحظ حتى الان اي وجود او نسمع عبر شهود
عيان بان ارتالا او سيارات او دعما عسكريا
قد وصل الى قوات الدعم السريعه التي
خرجت يوم الامس في الحدود الجنوبيه باتجاه
العاصمه الخرطوم بعد ان ارضيت كما قال
الجيش السوداني على مغادره القاعده الجويه
والمطر ما الذي يسيطر الان الاوضاع في
مروي هل يمكن حديث عن طرف ما هنا
لا الحديث بكل وضوح كما نلاحظ وكما نشاهد
وجود للقوات المسلحه وجود للدبابات في
مروي وجود لفرق متعدده تتبع لوحدات عسكريه
منتشره في محيط المحليه وامام المطار
والقاعده الجيش يقول بانه فرض سيطرته على
كل المطار وعلى كل القاعده ولا حديث الان
عن وجود لقوات الدعم السريع تتمركز داخل
مطار مروي بالتالي هناك سيطره تامه الان
يمكن القول في على مدار مروي من قبل الجيش
السوداني نزار
حتى الان يمكن ان نؤكد ذلك بان هنالك
سيطره كامله على مداخل ومخارج ومدرج
المطار والقاهره الجويه من قبل القوات
المسلحه السودانيه
في المطاره وفي محيط
لا وجود لعناصر الدعم السريعه نعم
ماذا عن الوضع الانساني في المدينه
الى طبيعتها المواطنون عادوا الى
ممارسه اعمالهم وانشطتهم الاقتصاديه
السوق الكبير في هذه المدينه الان بدا
رابط نشاطه المعتاد المحاله التجاريه فتحت
لاحظنا ايضا نشاطا مستمرا لحركه المواصلات
الداخليه داخل مدينه مروي
القرى المحيطه بمروي حركه المواطنين بدات
في التنقل
الاستعداد لعيد الفطر المبارك والشراء
المستلزمات المنزليه ايضا حركه السوق تشير
الى ان الحياه الان بدات تستعيد عافيتها
بعد ان توقفت خلال الايام الاربعه الماضيه
القاعده الجويه هناك هل من نباء او
معلومات مؤكده عن اوضاعها لنا
القاعده الجويه هي ملحقه بمطار مروي
الدولي والجيش الان يبسط له تماما على
محيط المطر والقاعده هل شهدت المدينه اي
اعمال سلب او نهب خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه جراء هذه المواجهات او عمليات
المطارده التي يقلنا تجري الان لملاحقه
عناصر الدعم السريع
الملاحقه تمت عبر الطيران الجوي وقبل عبر
سلاح الطيران لكن مدينه مروي لم تشهد
اشتباكات ولم تشهد مطاردات داخل الاحياء
ولم تشهد حرب مدن كل العمليه العسكريه وجل
العمليه والنشاط العسكري كان داخل محيط
القاعده والمطر اما مروي وبقيه القرى
وبقيه المدن فكانت بمنعه عن كل ما يدور
وكل ما دار خلال ساعه الماضيه
شكرا جزيلا لك نزار بقداوي المراسل
العربيه من مدينه المروي
وفي ساعه الاولى من صباح اليوم قال الجيش
السوداني انه تمكن من صده هجوم جديد من
قبل قوات الدعم السريع على محيط القياده
العامه في الخرطوم جدد بيان الجيش دعواته
لافراد الدعم السريع الى تسليم انفسهم
لاقرب وحده عسكريه واكد الجيش في بيانها
انه يمكن حسم المعركه بضربات جويه خلال
الساعات لكن الاولويه لحفظ ارواح المدنيين
مشيرا الى ان ذلك هو الفرق بين الجيوش
الوطنيه والمليشيات حسب البيع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع استمرار الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريعه التي تدخل يومها الخامس في
السودان قالت نقابه اطباء السودان عدد
الضحايا المدنيين ارتفعت الى 174 قتيلا
على الاقل وشارت الى تسجيل الفين واحد
واربعين حاله اصابه بين المدنيين التي
يقابلها نكسون فادح في رعايه الطبيه بسبب
تعرض بعض المستشفيات للاخلاء القصري
وذكرتني
بان نحو 30 مدنيا قتلوا في اشتباكات امس
رغم الاعلان عن الهدنه وقد دعت وزاره
الصحه السودانيه لايقاف العمليات المسلحه
التي طالت المرافق الصحيه في ولايه
الخرطوم ادت الى خروج 16 مستشفى عن الخدمه
فضلا عن صعوبه وصول الكوادر الصحيه
والاطباء الى المستشفيات وعدم تمكن سيارات
الاسعاف من اداء مهامها اشار ايضا وزير
الصحه هيثم ابراهيم الى ان القطاع الصحي
سيعاني من اثار كارثيه اضافيه مع اطاله
امد الصراع ووجه السوداني نداءات عاجله
الى ايقاف هذه الحرب والالتزام بفتح
مسارات امنه لسيارات الاسعاف وناشد ايضا
المنظمات الدوليه بضروره تقديم العون
بالامدادات الطبيه العاجله التي حددتها
الوزراء ومن جانبها اعلنت نقابه اطباء
السودان في بيانها توقف 39 مستشفى من اصل
59 بالعاصمه الخرطوم وقالت النقابه ان
تسعد مستشفيات تعرضت لقصف و16 تعرضت لخلاء
القسري ولفتت النقابه اطباء السوداني لان
المستشفيات العامه مهدده بالاغلاق بسبب
قصور اساسيات التشغيل ونقص المستلزمات
الطبيه
كما ناشد نائب رئيس نقابه الاطباء
السودانيه علي بشير في تصريحاته للعربيه
نشد بضروره توفير ممرات امنه لنقل واخلاء
المرضى مؤكدا ان الوضع الطبي اخذا في
الانهيار
حقيقه الوضع الانساني وضع كارثه
والنظام الصحي الان يمكن علينا ان نقول
انهمار تماما
يظل تعرض عدد من المستشفيات للقصف المباشر
وخروجها عن الخدمه
واخرها مستشفى فضيل الذي تعرض
للقذائف بالاسلحه الثقيله مما ادى الى
ثقبه في القائد المركزي وصهاريج المياه
الرئيسيه والمخططه لمرضى غسيل الكلى كما
ان هنالك عدد كبير من المستشفيات محدد
بالخروج عن الخدمه نتيجه لشح
النقود المطالب الاكثر الحاحا هي الالتزام
بالهدنه والعمل على الوقف الدائم لاطلاق
النار وقف هذه الحرب العبطيه
كما نطالب بفتح مسارات امنه وتحديدها
وتامينها من قبل هذه القواتة
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
مستشفيات تحت القصف قصف بالتوقيت الحرج لم
يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه
لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه
هذا مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار
تعرض للدمار بعد السقوط قذائف عشوائيه
عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قضاء في العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من
اكبر مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
تمت مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء ما انه ابدا ايجابي
بالعكس لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم
الاوضاع اكثر واكثر دعوات حقوقيه لوقف
اطلاق النار لفتح مسارات امنه لنقل
المساعدات الانسانيه للمدنيين وان تحققت
لفتره فثمت تحولات عسكريه بين حين واخر قد
تجعل الحاله اكثر ضبابيه
غيداء السالم العربيه
في استديوهاتنا معنا مديره مكتب العربيه
في الخرطوم لنا اهلا بك
بدايه
الكثير اليوم
وخاصه المنظمات الدوليه تتحدث عن ان
القطاع الصحي بشكل عام والمستشفيات في
السودان باتت على وشك الانهيار 39 مستشفى
الان من اصل 56 تقريبا اعلنت ايقاف
خدماتها واقتربت من هذا الخط يعني خلال
خمسه ايام تقريبا فبالتالي الى اي مدى
بالفعل اصبح
هذا القطاع المهم
منهارا اليوم في السودان
واقرب الى حاله الانهيار خرجت نصف
المستشفيات من الخدمه لنقص الكوادر الطبيه
والمستلزمات الطبيه لانقطاع عدد من
الخدمات من بينها طبعا الكهرباء والمياه
وكذلك مستوى النظافه الذي يمكن ان يكون في
هذه المستشفيات هناك كثير من الاطباء الان
يتحدثون انه ليس بامكانهم الوصول الى مقر
عملهم في المستشفيات وفي العيادات الصحيه
هناك حالات حرجه وهناك مرضى حتى من غسيل
الكلى الان هم في حاجه ماسه الى مواصله
العلاج لكن لا يمكنهم ذلك حينما نتحدث
الان عن انهيار هذا يعني الان توقف كل
المستشفيات ولكن لم تتوقف كل المستشفيات
الحاله الان اقرب الى التوقف الوضع الصحي
سيء للغايه تصلنا يوميا نحن في العربيه
مناشدات من قبل الاطباء والعاملين في هذه
المراكز الصحيه لاطلاق نداء استغاثه
اكيد لكل العاملين في المجال الصحي
للمنظمات لمن بامكانهم تقديم المساعده
للاطباء للصيادله حتى يتمكنوا ولو من
تخفيف هذا الضغط الضغط الهائل الموجود في
المستشفيات هذا الوضع اذا مستمر بهذه
الشكل كيف يمكن ان يؤثر على العاصمه
الخرطوم يعني
بولاياتها الموجوده فيها في بمناطقها ايضا
مختلفه والمتفرقه 56 مستشفى تبقى من 39
يعني تقريبا او 39 وعشره مستشفيات اكثر من
ذلك بالقليل يمكن ان تعمل في هذه الفتره
صحيح حينما نتحدث عن السودان فهو يشبه عدد
من الدول عاده التركيز يكون في العاصمه
افضل المستشفيات في السودان هي موجوده في
العاصمه سواء كان قطاع الحكومه او الخاص
وكانت الولايات السودانيه تبعث مرضاها الى
المستشفيات الرئيسيه الان يحدث العكس لان
الضغط موجود في الخرطوم لان اقوى
الاشتباكات موجوده في محيط القياده و
الخرطومه في منطقه ام درمان وكذلك في بحر
وهي اكثر المناطق التي فيها تمركز
للمستشفيات الان اصبح يحدث العكس الاسره
الان ترغب بان تذهب بمرضاها الى الولايات
السودانيه تواجههم مشكله اساسيه وهو
الطريق الطريق غير امن على الاطلاق اليوم
بثت كثير من الفيديوهات التي تشير الى
حاله عدم الامان الموجوده في هذه الشوارع
انتشار الدبابات حالات للسرقه تم تصويرها
في وقت السابق
ظهر فيها افراد من الدعم السريع الدعم
السريع لاحقا قال ان هؤلاء
افراد يعني
يرتدون فقط زي الدعم السريع اي انهم ليسوا
من الدعم السريع ولكن كل الصفحات الان حتى
صفحات تتبع للجان المقاومه صفحات تتبع
للاطباء تتحدث عن الاعتداءات التي تتم
السرقه وبالتالي الوضع الصحي لا ينفصل عن
الوضع العام الموجود ولكنه اكثر
عن الخدمه يعني نتحدث كنا في بدايه هذه
الازمه خلال ثلاثه ايام ولا اربعه ايام
الماضي بدات باربعه عشر ثم سته عشر ثم
الان 39 مستشفى فخارج الخدمه ماذا يحدث في
دارفور اذا كان هناك من انباء وصلت اليك
خاصه نواري شمال دارفور كان له التصريح
ملفت تبقى باننا ابلغنا الجيش والدعم
السريع رفضا استمرار القتال في الولايه
بالطابه طبعا ولايه دارفور وولايات دارفور
الخمسه لديها حساسيه وطبيعه خاصه الان نحن
نتحدث عن مقتل 24 شخصا بحسب احصاءات
والشمال دارفول طبعا
نلاحظ في هذه
الاونه ان هناك احصاءات تخرج من وزاره
الصحه احصاءات من نقابه الاطباء احصاءات
ممكن ان تصدر من الامم المتحده الان
والشمال دارفور هو يتحدث عن احصاءات لمقتل
24 شخصا وان هذه الاشتباكات مؤثره يتاثر
بها الكبار وحتى الاطفال وهو يناشد
الطرفين بوقف الاقتتال بولايته لانها ايضا
من الولايات لا تملك بنيه تحتيه جيده
وبامكان ان نتحدث عن انهيار سريع استمرت
الاشتباكات هناك ولكن اكثر الاشتباكات
التي تحدث الان هي في العاصمه ليست في
الولايات السودانيه لكن هناك امتداد لهذه
المعارك والاشتباكات الان بدات تخرج الى
الى خارج العاصمه وتمتد الى ولايه الجنوب
في الجنوب الغربي في في غيرها هنا ما
الخطور يعني الامتداد او الاستمرار الحرب
الان على مدى اكثر من هذه الايام ونحن
بدانا نلاحظ امتداد لهذه الحرب في عده
مناطق خاصه في الحدود مع اريتريا مع
اثيوبيا ايضا على سبيل صحيح خالد هنا
السؤال والاجابه تشير بصوره واضحه الى انه
لم تعد هناك منطقه امنه في السودان
حينما نتحدث كنا في وقت سابق عن اشتباكات
في الحدود مع اثيوبيا او في القضارف فهذا
يعني جزء شرقي حينما نتحدث عن اقتتال قبلي
في بورسودان او في كسله هي منطقه محدوده
حينما نتحدث عن اشتباكات واقتتال في
دارفور منطقه محدوده الخطوره تكمن ان
تتوسع هذه
الصراعات وهذه الرقعه من الحرب في مختلف
الولايات السودانيه وجهاتها المختلفه شرقا
وغربا وشمالا وجنوبا اخطر وسطا الان في
الخرطوم لذلك عدم الاحساس بالامان وعدم
قدره الاسره على النزوح الى الولايات من
العاصمه الخرطوم يشكل تهديد وهنا في هذه
الحاله هل ستاخذ الحرب بعدا
اعمق بتحولها الى حرب عرقيه مثلا في هذه
المناطق او غيرها
وربما يطل شبح الحرب الاهليه بشكل اكبر
خلال فترات القادمه من المتوقع خالد خاصه
في الولايات التي لديها بعد قبلي حينما
نتحدث عن دارفور فانا اذكر انني اشرت في
لك امس بان لدارفور الطبيعه خاصه لان قوات
الدعم السريع تسيطر كانت في دارفور وحينما
نشر الجيش السوداني امس خبر بانه سيطر على
احدى
المناطق في دارفور هذا امر له بعد اخر
ومختلف ليس مثل ان يحقق الجيش انتصارا حتى
في الخرطوم لان تمركز الدعم السريع
الاساسي متواجد في دارفور في حينما يحقق
الجيش
في تلك المناطق
تكون لديها مؤشرات مختلفه هناك في دارفور
البعد القبلي موجود والصراعات والقبليه لم
تتوقف في جنوب دارفور وغرب دارفور وهي
موجوده ان ينتقل الاقتتال من بين جيش ودعم
سريع او بين قوتين عسكريتين الى امر قبلي
فيه خطوره لاننا في هذه الحاله نشاهد
حالات انسانيه ستكون مختلفه واليوم قرات
منشور لاحد الاشخاص وهو يتحدث بان لديه
شقيق يعني انجب ابنا ولديه اخوان اثنين
واحد في الدعم السريع والاخر في الجيش فهو
يقول ان اسر ضابط الدعم السريع لدى الجيش
فيجب على شقيقه ان يبلغه بان شقيقهم انجب
طفلا وايضا الاخر فهذا يشير الى ان
التركيبه الموجوده بانتماءات الافراد الى
الدعم السريع او حتى الى الجيش داخل
الاسره الواحده فهذا امر خطير ويؤثر حتى
على النسيج الاجتماعي في السودان ومن
الواضح ان تصريحات المتبادله في اللغه بين
الطرفين تشير الى ان المعركه اصبحت الحرب
حتى الموت بين البرهان وحميتي لكن هل يمكن
لاحدهما بالفعل عن يقضي على الاخر هل
يستطيع الجيش التخلص من القوات في الدعم
السريع وسط هذه التركيبه يعني كل الطرفين
متوغلين داخل المجتمع السوداني في كل مكان
يعني هل يستطيع اي طرف التخلص من الاخر من
الصعب قال تصريح مهم جدا قال انه لا
يستهدف على الاطلاق جنود الدعم السريع
المشكله الان بين نعم بين الجيش وقيادات
الدعم السريع لذلك تمارس الان كثير من
التكتيكات من بينها مثلا بصوره وديه
يستلم افراد الدعم السريع بان يسلم افراد
الدعم السريع السلاح وبان ينضموا الى
الجيش هناك مناشدات الان تتم وهناك طبعا
طريقه اخرى وهي الطريقه العسكريه التي تتم
لذلك انا اقول لك خالد القضاء على يعني ان
يقضي طرف على الاخر هذا امر مستبعد
ومستحيل والاعداد كبيره جدا ولكن الان
الاستهداف يتم الى مناطق معينه فيها تمركز
فيها سلاح بعد ذلك اعتقد ان
يعني سيناريو الحرب الطويله هو الاكثر
ترجيحا بناء على هذه المعطيات اذا لم تكن
هناك تدخلات مؤثره يعني سواء كانت اقليميه
او داخليه او حتى الدوليه
حتى الان لا مؤشر على نجاح او تاثير مثل
هذه الافكار ربما او الوسطات وهناك انتظار
الى ربما غلب الطرف على اخر حتى يتسنى
الجلوس على طاوله المفاوض لكن الاخطر خلال
هذه الحربه ان ان هناك
شعب موجود ايضا قد ينحاز لطرف دون اخر
خلال فتره قادمه يعني هل ذلك ممكن هل
بدانا نرى اي مؤشرات على ذلك
الا انحياز نفسي لكن ليس بامكان المواطنين
المواطنين في السودان غير مسلحين ولا
اعتقد انهم سينحزون على طرف ضد اخر ولكن
هذه الحروب تسبب مرارات لدى الكثيرين يعني
كانت لدى الاسر ان اعتدى مثلا ضباط من
الدعم السريع او جنود من الدعم السريع على
مناطق او على اسر فهذا يشير بصوره واضحه
الى الى المراره التي ستكون ضد هذا الطرف
الان نحن نتحدث عن مواطنين يريدون ان
تتوقف هذه الحرب بين الطرفين لا يهمهم
الان الى متى ستستمر هذه الحرب كل ما
يهمهم الان هي ان تتوقف ولذلك هم يرحبون
باي وساطات تاتي باي مناشدات تاتي تجد ان
هناك اهتمام ولكنهم ايضا يعون في ذات
الوقت ان هذه المناشدات التي تاتي من
المجتمع الدولي ومن الامم المتحده بضروره
ايقاف الحرب بانها لن تسهم في هذا الامر
ما لم يكن هناك غالب ومغلوب بوقت قصير
ماذا تاثيرها هذه الحرب حتى الان خلال
خمسه ايام على الاسواق على على السلع على
حياه الناس التي تريد قضاء حاجياتها ايضا
الينا خالد هناك تاثير كبير جدا هناك
اسواق دمرت بالكامل هناك اسواق الان تعاني
من شح في عرض ما ترغب ببيعه للمواطنين نحن
نتحدث عن شهر رمضان الاحتياجات تكون فيه
مختلفه الان كثير من الناس لا يستطيعون
الوصول الى اسواق بعيده يعتمدون على
البقالات وعلى السوبر ماركتات القريبه من
منازلهم هي بحسب ما علمت حتى الان مفتوحه
ولكن قد ينفذ ما بها من بضاعه لانه لا
يوجد احد يستطيع التحرك سواء كان من
المصانع او الشركات ان يتحرك بسهوله في في
الشوارع لانهم يخشون من الاعتداء يخشون من
ان تذهب بضاعتهم هباء ماثوره لذلك انا
اؤكد لك بان خدمه الكهرباء
انقطاع خدمتين الكهرباء والمياه
نقص الغذاء
انعدام بعض السلع نقص الادويه الان كلها
امور تؤثر على حياه المواطنين بصوره
مباشره وتزداد سوءا يوما بعد يوم الان
وحسب هذا الاخبار العاجله تعلن قوات الدعم
السريع النقل الجنود المصريين الى من مروي
الى الخرطوم قوات الدعم السريع تقول ان
جميع الجنود المصريين بخير وسيتم تسليمهم
متى سنحت الفرصه نحن امام انفراج في هذه
الازمه اذن لنا اذا كان بالفعل تم نقلهم
الى الخرطوم هذه ستكون خطوه اولى ربما او
تمييديه لتسليمها لتسليمها الجنوب نعم
بالطبع وانا اذكر ان قائد الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلوق اشار
بصوره واضحه الى انهم كما تريد الحكومه
المصريه ان ارادت ان يتم تسليمه في سيتم
تسليمهم وان ارادوا ان يتم او ان يكونوا
في امان معهم فايضا لديهم هذا الخيار ولكن
طبعا في هذه الحاله هو الخيار المفضل
للجنود وكذلك للحكومه المصريه بان يذهب
الجنود الى بلادهم والحكومه المصريه كانت
تتابع هذا الامر عن كثب
في منطقه مروي واعتقد بان الجنود سيذهبون
الى الى مصر
نعود للمتابعه ايضا في تطورات هذا الملف
وقبل ان نكمل دعونا نلقي نظره على العلاقه
المتشابكه التي جمعت قائد الجيش عبد
الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدانو فيما تشاركه البرهان على مدى
السنوات الماضيه وما افسدته الرصاص التي
خرجت منذ خمسه ايام لتتحول بعدها السودان
الى ساحه حرب يديرها من كان يعد بحمايتها
وحليف الامس بات عدوا اليوم
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواها السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدرفورد اما وصفه الصداع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم
تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي تقاتل فيها
قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي افريقيا كان في
جنوب السودان وقتل حينها حوالي 400 الف
شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع استقرار جارتها
الشماليه وما يدور حاليا فيه قد ينتهي فقط
بفوز احدهم في المعركه مع عدم استبعاد حرب
اهليه طويله الامد قد تجر جيرانها وفق
صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه
ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه
تدعم القوات المسلحه السودانيه فيما اخبر
البرهان الصحيفه الغربيه انه بمجرد اكمال
الانتقال الى الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده
الى التكنات وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
من القاهره ينضم الينا السفير حمدي صالح
مساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري سيد حمدي اهلا
وسهلا بك معي اولا اخر التطورات متعلقه
بازمه الجنود المصريين في مروه يعني حسب
اعلان قوات الدعم السريع قبل قليل جميع
الجنود المصريين بخير سيتم تسليمهم متى
سنحت الفرصه قبل ذلك اعلنت هذه القوات نقل
الجنود المصريين من مروي الى الخرطوم هل
لديكم معلومات حول هذا الامر سيد حمدي
يعني ليس لدي معلومات دقيقه ولكن ارحب
بهذه الحركه ان تتحرك الجنود المصريه
يتحركوا الى الخرطوم ونامل ان يكونوا في
مكان امن كما صرح القائد الدعم السريع
ومساعديه
كما اشار الرئيس السيسي هؤلاء لم يكونوا
في السودان لدعم طرف دون طرف ولكن كان
هناك لمساعده الحكومه السودانيه وتدريبات
مشتركه وفقا لاتفاقيه مشتركه ولكن القضيه
الاساسيه المحوريه التي تتحرك فيها
الدبلوماسيه المصريه هي مستقبل الشعب
السوداني وامنه وبالتالي هناك قبل ذلك
سنذهب الى هذه النقطه لكن ان يتم تحريك
هؤلاء الجنود الان من مروي الى الخرطوم
العاصمه وسط هذه الاشتباكات المواجهات
الاحتلام دون الحديث عن الجهه التي
ستستلمها هذا ليس في الامر يعني خطوره على
على على هؤلاء الجنود
يعني انا لا اريد ان ادخل الى يعني
مناقشات في هذا النقطه لان طبعا هناك
خطوره وهناك قلق ولكن نامل ان يكون ما
يتحدث عنه الدعم السريع بانه سيسلم
سيتركهم في امنين في المنطقه ثم يعني
يعودون الى وطنهم نامل ان يكون هذا هو
الواقع
ولكن طبعا دي منطقه يعني منطقه خطره
الخرطوم هناك صراعات عنيفه كما اشارت
مديره مكتبكم عندما نتحدث عن الكرتون
بالذات ولكن في النهايه يعني ما يحدث
للمواطنين المصريين هو ما يحدث للشعب
السوداني ككل وبالتالي نحن نامل ان يكون
هناك وقف الاطلاق النار فوري وتتحرك
الاستراتيجيه المصريه لمحاوله اقناع
الطرفين بان يكون هناك وقفه اطلاق النار
وان يكون هناك مبادره شامله دوليه
للمساعده على تخفيف المعاناه للشعب
السوداني سواء من الكوارث التي لحقت به
بين الحرب سواء طبيا او انسانيا ونامل
لذلك الاستراتيجيه المصريه تحركت على
مستويات متعدده لهذا يعني رفع المعاناه عن
عن الشعب السوداني ونامل ان يكون هناك زي
اشاره المبادره شامله التي تتحرك فيها
هيئه الامم المتحده المشتركه فيها
المنظمات الاقليميه ومصر والدول العربيه
الخليجيه والسعوديه لكي تقدم دعم للجانب
الطبي للرفع المعاناه الانسانيه تاتي عن
طريق بورسودان اذا كانت كل
المطارات مغلقه فانه يجب ان يتحرك بشكل او
اخر يعني الحد من المعاناه الكارثيه التي
يعاني منها الشعب السوداني ولكن ايضا
تتحرك
يعني يكون هناك نظرا لما بعد اللحظه
الراهنه يعني يجب ان يكون وقف اطلاق النار
الذي كان هشا فالمرتين السابقتين او ثلاث
مرات السابقه ولم لم يطبق ان يكون وقف
اطلاق النار حقيقي مع وجود مراقبين دوليين
من تثبيته ووجود دوليه يعني الامل ان يكون
هناك مراقبين دوليين من الامم المتحده
لتثبيت وقف اطلاق النار كما يحدث في معظم
الصراعات التي حدثت في القاره الافريقيه
وفي اماكن اخرى وايضا يكون هناك يعني وضوح
للرؤيه من الذي سيغرق
وقف اطلاق النار وهي يجب ان يكون هناك
ضغوط دوليه عليه لعدم الحرق لوقف اطلاق
النار ولكن بالاضافه الى هذا مصر تتحرك
ايضا لضمان المواطنين الامن المواطنين
المصريين في السودان نحن لا نتحدث فقط عن
الجنود انما هناك عدد كبير من المواطنين
المصريين في السودان كانوا يعملون في الري
وفي التعليم وفي الطب وما اليه وبالتالي
دي قضيه محوريه تواجه كل الدول يعني
المانيا تتحرك لهذا لنقل المواطنيها معظم
الدول الاوروبيه فكر هذا مصر ايضا تضع خطه
للتحرك لضمان امن مواطنيها ولنقلهم في
حاله ان يكون هناك احتياج لهذا ولكن
التحرك الاستراتيجي المصري يؤكد او يركز
على فكره ان يكون هناك يعني ادنى من وقف
اطلاق النار من الهدنه لكي نتحرك للخطوات
للمستقبل يعني هناك تاكل في الثقه ما بين
الطرفين المتصارعين بحيث انه في الفتره
الاخيره زي ما شفنا رغم كل الجهود الدوليه
لها لا يتوقفوا مصر تحاول ان يعني ان تؤثر
بشكل او باخر على الطرفين وتجمع وتحشد
القوى الاقليميه العربيه والدوليه لكي
تضغط على الطرفين لكي يتوقفوا ونصل الى
نقطه معينه يكون فيها خدنا وممرات امنه
ولكن حتى الان لم تصل الاوضاع الى هكذا
حال يمكن من خلالها ان تدخل
السياسه او الوساطه يعني تعرف سيدي بانه
كل حربه وكل جوله عسكريه لابد ان تنتهي
سياسيا لابد من الجلوس على على الطاوله
هنا تدخل الوساطات المؤثره لكن يكون كل
ذلك مبني على نتائج
مواجهات هذه المواجهات العسكريه على الارض
الى الان الوضع جامد غير محسوم لكن لاي
طرف على الاخر لا سيطره لاي طرف على الاخر
حرب شوارع كر وفر وهنا يرجح ان تستمر هذه
الحرب كذلك لفتره اطول فالى اي مدى هذه
الدول ومصر تحديدا قادره على التعامل مع
تداعيات استمرار هذه الحرب لفتراتنا اطول
يعني زي ما اشرت المشكله الحقيقيه هي عدم
ادراك ادراك الجانبين
لموقفهم العسكري الحقيقي وما هو التوازن
العسكري بينهم كليهما يتصور انه يستطيع ان
يصل الى نقطه معينه ابعد من الاخر
وبالتالي هناك مرحله بيسمى مرحله ما قبل
الهدنه وما قبل السلام وهي ان كل طرف يعظم
مكاسبه ولكن في ضوء التوازنات الحقيقه
الحاليه في السودان والتوازنات الاقليميه
هناك مشكله حقيقيه وهي التداء امكانيه
التدخل من قوى اقليميه لمساعده طرفه على
طرف وما اليه وهذا يحدث حاليا وببعض
الاتهامات التي جاءت من الجيش السوداني من
هناك ذخائر تاتي الى الدعم الى الدعم
السريع مصر يعني تحس ان هذا خط احمر وخط
يعني خطير على السودان وعلى المنطقه ككل
لا يجب ان تتحول السودان الى منطقه اخرى
من الزراعات المستمره زي ما كما حدث في
ليبيا وفي اليمن وفي سوريا وما اليه
ونستمر في طويله السودان بالنسبه لمصر شعب
واحد تواجد المصري السودانيين في مصر
دلوقتي اربعه مليون وقد يزيد في المستقبل
الارتباط بالسودان ارتباط عميق وبالتالي
اي تاثير على على التطورات التي تحدث في
السودان من القوى الاجنبيه والتي تؤدي الى
لتاجيل الصراع واستمراره بالشفاء طويله
ستؤثر تاثير خطيره على الامن القومي
المصري وعلى الامن القومي السوداني
وبالتالي مصر بتاخذ كل هذه الخطوات
والمبادره الاخيره التي يتحدث عنها مصر
التي قدمت نقاط معدة محدده تنفيذيه لوقف
اطلاق النارس ومراقبين ثم مفاوضات ثم
الوصول الى نقطه وسط واعطاء افق افق
مستقبلي للطرفين هذه هذه المبادره تحاول
ان تبعد قطر التدخل الاجنبي تبعد خطر
الصراع ان يستمر وثم ان تحاول ان يعني
تدفع بالمجتمع الدولي ان يقدم ما يستطيع
ان يقدمه لحل هذه المشكله لذلك ربما هنا
اريد فقط ان
يقرا ما جاء في بيان قوات الدعم السريع
حول
الجنود المصريين مما جاء بانه سيتم
تسليمهم متى سمحت الفرصه ماذا يعني ذلك
متى ستسمح الفرصه لماذا يعني وجودهم في
الخرطوم هل هو مرتبط
بتطورات المعركه اليوم البعض يذهب مثلا
بانه قد يقود الى راي استخدام هؤلاء
الجنود كدروع بشريه في بعض المناطق التي
تبدو فيها هذه القوات قوات الدعم السريع
تشعر بالضعف في في محيطها ربما
يعني انا لم اريد اتطرق لهذه النقطه امل
ان لا يحدث هذا
ويعني اثق في كلام قائد القوات الدعم
السريعه اللي بيقول انهم امنين سيكونوا
امنين هذه نقطه مهمه لا يجب ان يستخدم هذا
الوضع للزج في مصر بمصر في الصراع الداخلي
عن طريق استخدامهم كدروع او ماليه المصدر
يعني سياستها عدم التدخل في الاوضاع
الداخليه للدول المجاوره ولا لاي دوله
وبالتالي لا تريد ان تدخل في القضايا
السودانيه وتريد الاطراف الصينيه ان تتحرك
سويا لحل مشاكلها لا لا نامل الا تستخدم
هذه القضيه للزج بمصر في الصراعات
الداخليه ونعمل ان يكون هناك يعني وضع امن
لهؤلاء الجنود انا معك ان الوضع خطر في في
الخرطوم اكثر خطوره من مروي وبالتالي ده
بيعرضهم اكثر للخطر ولكن امل ان لا يكون
هذا ما سيحدث شكرا جزيلا لك حمدي صالح
السفير ومساعد وزير الخارجيه المصري
الاسبق
دعونا معكم نتابع هذه الصور الخاصه
بالعربيه من مطار الخرطوم
قد تمكن فريق العربيه من الدخول والتجول
ظهر اليوم في مطار مروي الدولي والقاعده
الجويه العسكريه الملحقه بالمطار واظهرت
صور العربيه حجم الضرر الذي لحق بالبنيه
التحتيه للمطار فضلا عن تدمير جزء كبير من
برج المراقبه في المطار في وقت قال فيه
الجيش نوبات يسيطر تماما على مداخل ومخارج
ومحيط القاعده والمطر
العربيه والحدث في هذا اليوم الاربعاء
التاسع عشر من ابريل لعام 2023 داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه وداخل مطار مروي الدولي هذا
المطار الذي كان مسرحا لعمليات عسكريه
خلال خمسه ايام مضت هو الان بهذه الوضعيه
وبهذه الشاكله بعد اشتداد العمليات
العسكريه والحربيه والاشتباكات بين قوات
الجيش السوداني وبين قوات الدعم السريع
هذه الصور التي تتابعونها حصريا على
العربيه والحدث لاننا وصلنا الان قبل قليل
الى هذا المطار بعد ان اصبح بسيطره كامله
تحت قياده الجيش السوداني وتحت سيطره
القوات المسلحه السودانيه التي انتشرت عبر
الاليات وعبر المدفعيه وعبر الدبابات
الثقيله هذا هو المطار بوضعيته الراهنه
بعد خمسه ايام من عمليات عسكريه على اشدها
شهدتها هذه المنطقه وهذه القاعده العسكريه
الاستراتيجيه العملياتيه الجويه بشمال
السودان في منطقه مروي طائرات عسكريه حسب
ما نرى الان في الصوره لم تتضرر هنالك بعض
الطائرات تضررت هذا المكان الذي تشاهدونه
الان هو يقدم الخدمات اللوجستيه للطائرات
ايضا تضرر وتاثر بفعل الاشتباكات والضربات
العنيفه التي حدثت في هذه المنطقه الان
هذا المطار وهذا الجزء من المطار هو حيوي
يتعلق بهبوط بقيام الطائرات التدريبات
كانت في هذا المكان الان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تنتشر في محيط وفي ارجاء هذا
المكان تتمركز في مختلف الاتجاهات في
الاتجاه الشمالي في الاتجاه الجنوبي وفي
الاتجاه الغربي وفي الاتجاه الشرقي حسب
افادات خاصه للعربيه والحدث بان الجيش
السوداني القوات المسلحه السودانيه الان
تف بالكامل على كل مداخل ومخارج هذا
المطار والقاعده العملاتيه الجويه هنا في
مدينه مروي شمال السودان يوم الامس دارت
اشتباكات عنيفه على اثرها
غادرت قوات الدعم السريع واضطرت بحسب بيان
للجيش السوداني لمغادره هذه القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه شمالا بعدها
مباشره
تعاملت الطيران او تعامل الطيران الجيش
السوداني مع من خرج من هذه القاعده وكبدهم
خسائر فادحه بحسب ايضا مصادر عسكريه الان
هذا المطار بكلياته بكامله في يد الجيش
السوداني ويدى القوات المسلحه من داخل
مطار مروي الدولي ومن داخل القاعده
العسكريه الجويه العملياتيه نزار البغداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث
نذهب الى الخرطوم حيث ينضم الينا من هناك
رئيس تحرير منصه اخبار وراء محمد شمس
الدين سيد شمس الدين اهلا وسهلا بك معي في
هذه التغطيه
استعادت الجيش السيطره على المطار وعلى
القاعده الجويه في مروي ما مدى تاثير على
سياق الحرب والمواجهات بين حميتي والبرهان
الجيش والدعم
تحيه طيبه لك يا اخي خالد
لضيوفك الكرام ولساده المشاهدين اينما
كانوا يعني
هذا المطار بطبيعه الحال هو كان هو الهدف
الاول لهذه القوات منذ ايام وذلك لاهميه
هذا المطار وهذه القاعده الجويه
الاستراتيجيه بالنسبه
لحديدا وقوات الدعم السريع اذ تنقصه سلاح
او ينقصه سلاح الطيران وفي حال تمكنه من
السيطره على هذا المطار بمرافقه واجهزه
الاتصالاته وكل تفاصيله فان ذلك كان ليغير
المعادله ان تمكن من على ما في المطار من
طائرات وغيره فان ذلك كان ليلعب دورا
كبيرا في هذه
المعركه تحديدا خاصه وان هناك تقارير رشحت
في الفتره الماضيه في السنوات الماضيه بان
قوه الدعم السريع كانت قد دربت مجموعه من
عناصرها على الطيران في اكثر من من بلد
يعني اصبح لديها طيارون اصبح لديها عدد من
الطيارين الجاهزين ولكن
ينقصه
الطائرات هذا في سياق يعني التحليل الذي
استمعنا اليه في الفترات الماضيه
فيما يتعلق بانعكاسات ذلك او تبعات هذا
الامر ايضا هذا قد يشير الى ان هذه القوات
التي كانت تتمركز في تلك المنطقه قد تتجه
يعني باتجاه مواقع اخرى حيويه وربما
الوجهه الاولى لهم هي المطار قبل قليل
ايضا استمعنا الى تسريب لمكاله لاحد عناصر
الدعم السريع الذين كانوا يتحدثون الى احد
ضباط الجيش من سياق الحديث فهمنا ذلك
وكانت الاسئله تدور يعني حول او الحديث
يدور حول امكانيه التسليم ويعني وضع من
سيسلمون انفسهم وما الى ذلك تحدثوا عن
تفاصيل كثيره وعن ان هناك يعني اعداد
كبيره من هذه العناصر تعاني الان في هذه
اللحظات من جراء يعني الجوع
العطش هذا الامر شاهدناه بالامس هو اليوم
بالعين المجرده هذه العناصر تحوم داخل
الاحياء
يعني جراء الارهاق فهي تستلقي تحت الاشجار
امام ابواب البيوت في سياق الحديث
حول ان بعض يعني كيف يمكن سيد محمد شمس
الدين من بعض الناس في الاحياء وفي البعض
الاخر لا يتلقون ذلك العون هذا يعني ان
الامدادات الغذائيه ايضا طالت يعني هذه
الاشكاليه طالت هؤلاء ايضا ليس فقط جميع
المتقاتلين الان في هذه الظروف شاهدناهم
ايضا في اوقات سابقه وهم يحرمون يعني وقد
تمكنوا من الحصول على بعض ما في سوبر
ماركتات الصغيره في احياء يحملون المياه
زجاجات المياه وايضا هناك لقطات خرجت لبعض
سوبر ماركتات الكبيره في منطقه العمارات
وقد تم اقتحامها بالكامل يعني بطبيعه
الحال بهدف الحصول على المعونه الغذاء
الذي يعني يمكنه من الصمود ايضا في سياق
الحديث اذا كان هناك وعود بحسب ما كان
يتحدث
عنصر الدعم السريع بعود من القيادات بان
هناك طائرات اغافيه ستاتي من طرف الامم
المتحده وما الى ذلك حتى تساندهم في اطار
تصبيرهم على
يعانونه الان من هذه
المواجهات المستمره والمتواصله ايضا كان
هناك او كانت هناك معلومه حول مساله ان
لماذا ايضا لا يسلم الباقيين انفسهم سريعا
ويستفيدوا من فكره او مساله العفو كان
الرد من قبل عشره الدعم السريع يقول بان
هناك تعليمات لجميع الافراد بان من يتراجع
او يفكر في تسليم سلاحه فان هناك اوامر
لاقرب زميل له لان يطلق عليه الرصاص
ويصفيه فورا فهذا هو احد التفسيرات ايضا
التي تفسر طول امد هذه المواجهات ليس من
خيار امام عنصر سريع فيما يتعلق بتراجعه
عبر
زملائي اريد ان اخذ وجهه نظرك الان في
تحرك الاخير اذا كنت اسمعني سيد شمس الدين
هل تسمعني الطريق الوحيد ايضا قبل قليل
بيان الجيش يؤكد ان هناك
ازمه حقيقيه بين القوات الدعم السريع فيما
يتعلق بالحصول على
الغذاء يتحدث البيان عن ان العناصر باتوا
يسلموا
بعض تقارير الى الاهالي يستبدلون هذا
السلاح
الاول انه سيستبدلونه بالماء والطعام او
يقومون ببيعه من اجل الحصن ربما يعني شراء
يعني الطعام من اي مكان قد تحدثنا عنه
مفتوح هذه كلها
اعتذر لمقاطعتك اشكرك شكر جزيل رئيس تحريم
منصه اخبار وراء محمد شمس الدين من
الخرطوم
عليكم
اعوذ لمديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطومنا
ربما اريد ان نعرج على بيان الدعم السريع
الاخير حول الجنود المصريين بانه نقلهم
الى الى العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم سؤال
عن نقلهم هل الدعم قوات الدعم السريه هي
جاده في عمليه التسليم تريد الاستفاده
منهم ربما كورق الضغط سياسيه
عسكريا ايضا في وسط هذه المواجهات
المحتدمه الان في الخرطوم
طبعا حاولت الاستفاده منهم سياسيا سيشكل
هذا الامر يعني ضغط عليها ايضا من الرايه
العام اعتقد انها لن تكسب باي حال من
الاحوال ان حاولت الاستفاده السياسيه لكن
الاقرب مصر يعني منوي الاقرب مصر ولكن
لانهم خسروا هذه القاعده خسروا مطار مروي
ونحن قبل قليل نشاهد هذه اللقطات التي
اعدها مراسلنا في الخرطوم من قاعده ومن
مطار مروي تشير الى ان الجيش الان سيطره
تماما على مروي اذن
قامت دعم السريع بنقلهم الى الخرطوم
وراينا اليوم دبابات هل هناك مناطق مسيطر
عليها قوات الدعم السريع حتى يتم تامين
هؤلاء الجنود في الخرطوم اعتقد اعتقد ان
انها قد تنقله الى اماكن سريه لدى الدعم
السريع في حال وقع هؤلاء الجنوط طبعا في
قبضه الجيش السوداني بلا شك
سيتم
التوثيق مع الظاهره في كيفيه ايصالهم ولكن
اعتقد ان الدعم السريع نقلهم لانه خسر
مروي الان هذا جانب الجانب الاخر بعيدا عن
الجنود المصريين كثير من الدول الان تحاول
اجلاء رعاياها لكن
تعمل على ذلك نعم خالد اليابان وكذلك
المانيا وكذلك دول عده مطار الخرطوم الان
تدمر او شبه تدمر اي انه لا يصلح الان
للعمل حتى ان توقفت الحرب ما لم تحدث فيه
صيانه كبيره ما هي البدائل المتاحه
البدائل المتاحه ربما من الانسب استخدام
مطار بورسودان مطار بورسودان هو لا يسع
كثيرا
لكل طبعا رحلات الطيران هو مطار محدود جدا
للسفريات الداخليه ولكن منذ سنوات اصبح في
المطار رحلات دوليه الى جده الى القاهره
الى دول محدده اذا استخدام هذا المطار في
حال توقفت الحرب هو الخيار الارجح ولكن
مطار الخرطوم لم يعمل الان الطريق البري
ايضا هو قد يكون متاح عبر جوبا عبر
اريتريا عبر اديس ابابا عبر القاهره كذلك
البحر يمكن ان يتم نقل اي رعايه لاي دوله
عبر البحر وعبر ميناء بورسودان هذه هي
الان الطرق التي قد تكون متاحه للدول
لاجلاء وانقاذ رعاياها شكرا جزيلا يعقوب
مديره مكتب العربيه في الخرطوم
دعونا نلقي نظره اخرى على معاناه المدنيين
الجراء هذه المواجهات المستمره حيث سقطت
الكثير من الضحايا من بينهم الطبيبه
الشابه ابنه كابتن الهلال ومدربه السابق
فوزي المرضي بينما اصيبت والدتها جراء
رصاصه طائش اصابه نافذه منزلهم في ام
درمان
طلبت
بس ابتلاه اخوها بالعربيه طلعه بمصر
الاحياء وشجاب
وصلت البيت مبسوطه جدا مرتاحه
لو عملت لي فنجان قهوه لان انا انا فاطر
جدا لما طلعت من الاوضه الصغيره في
الصالون به هناك
مشيت امه قالت
الشباك
مختلفه القزاز
كثره القزاز ضربت امها في الاول في الفقه
الايمن
بتاع الفجر
ضربت البنت في قلبها
في قلبها مباشره
وقعت
متوفيه توفى الطوال في الحال
في الجهد الاقليميه للتهدئه تلقى وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اتصالا من نظيره الامريكي
تركز على الوضع في السودان واكد الامير
فيصل بن فرحان وبلنكن خلال الاتصال على
اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكري في السودان
وضروره حمايه المدنيين والاجانب كما شدت
على اهميه امن واستقرار السودان وشعبه
وقبل ذلك وفي ذات السياقه وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري ان بلاده ستكثف
الاتصالات على اطراف السودانيه المتنازعه
من اجل استئناف الحوار السلمي لتسويه
الوضع بينهما وجدد شكريه تاكيد على ضروره
امتناع جميع اصحاب المصلحه والنفوذ
الاجانب عن تصعيد الوضع في السودان معبرا
عن امله في التواصل الى حل قريب بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع نعيد التذكره هنا بمن
كشفته مصادر خاصه للعربيه التحركات
المصريه اقليميه تشمل دخول مراقبين دوليين
للوصول الى وقف اطلاق النار خلال عيد
الفطر وفتح ممرات ام بين مصر والسودان
لمده 48 ساعه للسماح بنقل المصابين ودخول
المساعدات الانسانيه بالاضافه الى تخصيص
لجنه امميه دوليه وتسهيل دخولها للاشراف
على كافه الاسرى من الجانبين وتسهيل مهام
بعثات الامم المتحده وبرنامج الغذاء
العالمي من خلال تعيين قوه خاصه لتامين
مهامهم داخل الاراضي السودانيه كما كشفت
المصادر ايضا عن وجود مشاورات حول تشكيل
لجنه دوليه محايده مسؤوله عن التحقيق في
الاحداث الحاليه في السودان
الى ذلك اكدت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض
كريم جانبير انه لا يوجد لدى الاداره
الامريكيه اي خطط لعمليات اجلاء من
السودان وسط التواصل يطلق النار بكثافه في
الخرطوم
لعمليات
اجنبي رعايه امريكيه مع تواصل اطلاق النار
في الخرطوم رغم بدء سريان الهدنه ادعو
جميع الامريكيين في السودان التحسن بمكان
امن
الاخباريه من رياض انتهت تغطيتنا متواصل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات